hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel glad you
can join me for today's video I want to
talk about uh you know accumulation and
distribution which are important
Concepts in the analysis of order flow
okay and it refers to you know sort of
the the buy and sell orders that are
executed in the market and it provides
insights into the underlying market
dynamics and can be useful for
identifying um you know sort of
potential changes in Market sentiment
and price trends all right but before we
jump in if you enjoy learning from these
videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel and click the notification Bell
so that you never miss a new upload and
if you find today's video helpful be
sure to hit the uh like button and leave
a comment below you know I love uh
reading your feedback you know sometimes
it's positive sometimes it's negative
but you know really what these videos
are it's for discussion on orderflow um
you know it's here so you can learn more
about uh understanding the order flow
all right so you know when people talk
about accumulation right generally you
know people will we look at a um you
know a chart and you know a simple bar
chart and they'll say oh there's
accumulation down here and there's
distribution up here but okay you know
you're sort of guessing after the fact
right after a low has been made after a
high has been made um you know if you
read on you know woff you know he wrote
a lot about the accumulation and
distribution and when you're looking at
the order flow okay you're actually
seeing the volumes that trade on the bid
the volume's trading on the offer and it
can help you make a uh good decision on
is there accumulation taking place right
now right because when you're using
order flow right you're using the most
recent data in the market as it's
happening that's what makes orderflow so
unique as a tool and so powerful as well
because you are actually basing your
decisions on what's happening right now
in real time okay and often times you
can see the bids well always you can see
the bids and the offers and there's
there's sometimes where it's a bit out
of whack okay so you know perfect
example is this bar here now I'm looking
at the the uh this is 10year notes right
this is a four range chart I've always
used a four range chart on um interest
rates you know the 10 the bonds the
fives um you know now you got the ultra
tens Ultra bonds as well it just serves
me makes it a lot easier to read as
opposed to a minute based chart but
really what you're doing is you're
focusing in on the volumes that trade
now you're not trying to pick apart
every single tick that goes through but
you're looking for things that stand out
because what is accumulation okay now
accumulation and distribution is sort of
the opposite sides of the spectrum so
I'll spend time talking about
accumulation and sort of the opposite is
true taking place for distribution I
don't think I I would need to go over
that but think of it in the opposite
terms okay so accumulation right it's
sort of the process that institutional
Traders you know investors you know real
money accounts large Traders are
gradually acquiring a position in the
market okay and this is basically done
in strategic manner right why it's
because they want to avoid causing
significant price movements that could
work sort of against their objective of
putting on a
position okay so during this when
accumulation takes place right it's
characterized by um increased buying
activity right it's a accumulation right
and when someone's accumulating they're
buying Distributing is someone getting
rid of a position so you're going to
sort of see a combination of thing
you're going to see high volume buying
okay and you're often going to see an
absorption of selling pressure okay so
when you see a bar like this nice green
bar here in the middle at
9003 what do you see right you see some
aggressive buying you know you got a
couple buying and balances here 11 1 ,16
2759 but you also see strong passive
buying here people that are absorbing
whatever selling is taking place
4,270 okay it's actually your heaviest
volume in the bar on the bid side so you
have some absorption taking place you
have aggressive trading taking place
okay and why is the absorption
important well it's going to keep price
stable
right price is not going to drop you
know maybe we get through the
absorption by a tick or two but if it's
holding right and you have that strong
buying that is a sign of absorption and
again distribution would would you know
be the same on the opposite side okay
you're going to look for um some signs
of absorption from the aggressive buying
let's see if we could sort of find one
here uh really
quick okay you know there's a few in
here actually on this move down um sort
of the most obvious one is in my opinion
is up here right 8591 so you got some
strong absorption for you got strong
buying coming in but you got absorption
taking place here right you have this
buying imbalance right then you see
aggressive selling taking place in this
bar and even in the next bar right as
the market starts going down so
distribution and accumulation you know
the opposite sides of the spectrum now
it can be difficult for Traders
especially those that are new to
orderflow trying to you know figure this
out and going to be sitting is this
absorption you know is this distribution
or is this um accumulation taking place
is there aggressive trading taking place
that is why you know on the orderflows
trader software we have a tool actually
to make your life a lot easier it's
called the accumulation distribution so
you just click it right and really what
you the the filter it out for stronger
trades is you want to put passive
Traders are in control as well okay so
enable it and add passive traders in
control and you click
okay and it will highlight the bars that
have accumulation or distribution taking
place okay and it's going to
color the box or a price level in the
bar where accumulation is taking place
why is it covering these areas because
that's you know an area that ideally you
want to beong from so you can see right
distribution accumulation accumulation
accumulation here didn't work
accumulation accumulation right
accumulation people say well this one
didn't go up well you got the signs much
earlier um right now this bar is forming
you know just going back you know in an
evening session right this is the reopen
here going up accumulation accumulation
now it's not just
about finding the bar that has
you know a green candle with heavy
volume on the bid side heavier than any
price level on the offer side there's a
little bit more that goes into it but
you can see right if there's
accumulation right if there's um you
know some distribution taking place
distribution accumulation okay this is
during the number um this is actually
right before the number
but often times right when I'm looking
at accumulation I'm I'm not going to use
use this tool in every Market I think
it's best suited to markets that are
really driven by supply and
demand uh factors right equities driven
by all sorts of things right it's driven
by um you know politicians trading no um
you know it's driven by a lot options
activities where Traders and a lot of
retail activity right and you know when
you're looking at interest rates right
it's it's a lot of when majority
overwhelming majority is institutional
Traders so if you were to look at you
know like the whole curve even um you
know go out to the ultra
bonds okay same tool right where am I
here if there's any signal right here
right here right accumulation
accumulation
distribution right signs of
accumulation all night right from
Midnight nice move up you know here's
distribution yes yest right move up
distribution
distribution right here's some
accumulation as you're just going
sideways in the morning but you know
you're not going to trade during the
number um you know even out to the five
years okay closer in on the
curve take a look here right
accumulation accumulation distribution
distribution distribution
and it's a great little tool especially
if you're just trying to squeeze out you
know a few ticks again you know I know a
lot of traders that trade um the
interest rates and and really they're
just trying to squeeze out a few ticks
here and there because they're able to
move size I mean it's easy to move size
in a market that trades a lot of size
right you can see here you know each
price level there's several thousand
more or less so it's easy to get in easy
to get out with size all right even
today here right just good size all
around and again you know when
you're um thinking about accumulation
and and distribution in the order flow
it's going to give you Insight sort of
into you the underlying market dynamics
and more importantly potential future
price movements right again it's not
about trying to pick a reversal point
it's letting the market tell you hey
there's potential distribution taking
place there's potential accumulation
taking place okay because accumulation
patterns you know may signal the
potential for a bullish Trend while
distribution may suggest the possibility
of a bearish
trend okay and what makes it even more
powerful you know orderful that is is
when you combine it with other Technical
and fundamental analysis that you
already use in your own trading right
you don't have to use this in a vacuum
right if if you have a level right if
you say oh you know what my Pivot level
is up here at uh you know 19 and a half
right this 19 and a half and then you
see distribution coming in you could be
more confident in that
trade that the market could potentially
sell off all right you know that really
that's that's the beauty that sort of
gets lost on people sometimes it's it's
not that you got to throw out everything
you've learned about um you know trading
when you pick up order flow no when you
start combining it with how you
understand the market tools that you're
already using it could be a big um help
for
you in your trading
results so you know I hope that explains
a bit of uh you know accumulation and
distribution and you know just one last
thing before before I I sign off here
is you know you hear the term markets
are fractal okay and really what that
means is you know Concepts that work on
a daily chart weekly chart if it's a
legitimate way of analysis it will work
on a minute chart it'll work on a one
minute chart right it it's the concepts
that only work on one specific chart
type don't last very long right it may
just be um you know a short-term thing
you know that's why people always talk
about losing their Edge right so I
developed an edge but it's gone now well
it's because it was very specific for
that moment in time right and you know
with with orderflow you're able to see
things sort of on on a micro level and
you know again if you know when people
talk about accumulation and distribution
they think in terms of long-term trading
right someone's accumulating a position
to hold for months but you know when
you're looking at the order flow you
could see when there's accumulation and
distribution taking place in the short
term so anyway guys I'll end the video
on that note and again you know that
this is a tool that comes with the order
flows Trader 7
software it's called accumulation
distribution and it's more powerful when
you add passive traders in control all
right everyone so take care and I'll see
you guys on the next video